good morning hickets tuesday so my
all-time favorite meme is how do you do
fellow kids it's from a scene in the tv
show 30 rock in which
then 55 year old steve buscemi dress up
as a high school student and says how do
you do fellow kids
the meme first appeared almost a decade
ago meaning that it is itself becoming
old and thereby becoming
more meta every day like as caitlyn
tiffany has written the fellow kids meme
is out of touch out of date and totally
out of place in its current context it
is a meme
of a meme jeff's kiss there's a lot to
dislike about meme discourse but god i
love it's turtles all the way down
recursion but what i love most about how
do you do fellow kids is that it reminds
me of a lesson that at times i have
learned the hard way
if i try to act hip and relatable to a
young audience it will only feel
mega cringe to use some probably
outdated slang
anyway my point is that i don't know
what it's like to be in your teens or
20s today i can't relate to those
experiences as a peer i can listen and i
can try to empathize but i can't know
what it's like from the inside
similarly i don't know what it's like to
experience vaccine hesitancy the vast
majority of people watching this are
either vaccinated in the process of
getting vaccinated or
desperate to get vaccinated and i know
many of you
cannot yet access vaccines and i am
sorry and we need to
dramatically increase supply and
distribution but there are also people
watching this video who feel vaccine
hesitancy or who find the prospect of
getting vaccinated against covid
stressful or overwhelming for whatever
reason
and i have to say i sympathize with
those people i've had severe anxiety for
most of my life and one of the things
i've learned living with it is that for
me
shame just isn't very effective like
being told to stop worrying or that i'm
an idiot for worrying about things that
aren't rational
that doesn't help me ultimately i don't
find it helpful to judge myself for my
uncertainties or anxieties what i find
helpful is figuring out a way to
overcome them the coveted vaccines
approved in the u.s and much of the
world are safe and effective over 100
million people have already received
them and they dramatically reduce both
the personal
and societal risk of kovid if everyone
were fully vaccinated tomorrow
covid19 would be at most a minor problem
for humans but to get there or anywhere
close to there we must not just be
inoculated against the disease as
individuals but also as communities now
there are some people who just refuse to
get vaccinated and that's their choice
but a much larger percentage of people
are hesitant for a variety of reasons
maybe their information feeds have
misinformed them about vaccination maybe
they don't trust the health care system
maybe they find it difficult to make an
appointment maybe they are personally at
low risk and so feel like getting the
vaccine isn't a priority
but the thing is immunity is not really
a personal trait as
eu abyss has written immunity is a
public space
like you getting vaccinated radically
reduces your personal risk of being
harmed by kovid but every person who is
immunized
lessens kovid's ability to spread and
infect the vulnerable
from smallpox to typhoid we have learned
over and over again that immunity only
really works when it is shared and so
you getting vaccinated is something you
do for yourself but it's also something
you do for your
community that's why you getting
vaccinated matters to me and
me getting vaccinated matters to you
when encouraging people in my life to
get vaccinated i'm trying hard not to be
like how do you do fellow vaccine
hesitants
i don't want to pretend that we have the
same information feeds or the same
perspectives on public health but i also
don't want to shame people both because
i don't think that worry and uncertainty
are shameful
and because i don't think shame works
what helps me when i feel fear and
uncertainty isn't
shame but support and reassurance and
empathy
so if you're worried that's okay ask for
help and if you're trying to support
someone
offer help i think in the end that's all
we can do we can't make other people's
choices for them
but i also know that the only way we're
gonna end this is together
hank i'll see you on friday oh you
didn't think i was going to leave you
without a vision board did you i am
thankful for safe and effective vaccines
and hopeful that we can achieve
shared immunity soon